why did jordan peterson all of a sudden
become mainstream
why did jordan peterson all of a sudden
blow up the way he did what did he start
talking about because he's pushing a
message that people were longing for say
that again he's pushing a message that
people they're they're longing for it
they're hurting for it they want to hear
it so he gave a message about what it is
to be a man okay so he's helping boys
become men he's talking about personal
responsibility bingo the 12 rules of
life
clean your bed you know make your do
this all these basic to think about
nothing he said
is like e equals m c square oh my god
everything he said is just basic stuff
that you know
many people a generation ago were being
taught that it skipped a generation that
they're not teaching
i'm going to keep saying this over and
over again this goes back to values and
principles
this goes back to values and principles
choose a religion okay
that has got the right values and
principles and start telling schools to
pray i don't care what it is whether
it's prayer values and principles ten
commandments i don't care which one of
these it is
make it a requirement to start teaching
basic values and principles now
of course
adam's got a very good point because the
responsibilities on the parent
so where this goes even more to
uh you know a single family household
where you know there's a single parent
household kids are being raised by that
but this this has to be the main if
there's any books that you can write
right now that i believe will do very
well that people want to read if there's
any channels you can create any content
you can create anything you can write
about anything you can build
your mo of your youtube channel your
blog your website your whatever you're
doing
this has this will do very very well
right now the next 5 10 15 20 years and
i don't think this is gonna go away any
time soon
because most of the churches that you go
to nowadays a lot of them are out of
touch this is being run by a 72 year old
pastor and he's given messages that just
he has a hard time connecting with the
audience i went to a couple of them i
won the biggest churches in dallas i
went to i sat there on easter and i said
dude you just don't connect with me i
have a hard time connecting with you
where's dudley rutherford who connected
with everybody in la right
i think there's a big opportunity in
churches and i think there's a big
opportunity for people who are teaching
the right morals the right values and
the right principles until we start
doing that and by the way
my messaging of what i'm saying guess
how long the shift is going to take with
my strategy how long do you think a long
time 20 decades
20 years by the decades but by the way
uh
not to bring it back to what uh i'm
doing but um i'm going to bring it back
to what i'm doing you will find within
the latino community in the united
states and latinos in general the
adherence to parental obedience is
bigger and better than it is in most
other cohorts
for some reason
when i fear my dad's gonna kick my ass
for something i even thought before i
did it i tended not to do it and we are
raised that way
it's a moralistic kind of teaching but
somehow maybe it comes from catholicism
i don't know
uh maybe it comes from our own sense of
uh christianity maybe it does maybe it
doesn't i'm not saying everybody has to
be like uh think like me because i
happen to be a christian but something
in the latino dna makes people
less apt to want to be lazy and more apt
to be want to work and have accept
personal responsibility and and when i'm
doing uh rick sanchez news my podcast
that's something i constantly try to
make sure that i talk about because it's
a it's about fitting the people to the
argument no matter what the story is on
that day which which makes me think as
we're discussing this you're probably
going to be less apt to see that kind of
behavior in our community well i think
which is a good thing but having human
friends uh i think it comes down to the
chancleta yeah they get they'll take you
a sandal and i hit you over there and i
don't know what your parents used to hit
me with my dad it was a belt but in the
cuban household in miami they'll take a
smile my mother used to see the front
porch in our house
in other words i'm not going to hit you
i'm not going to hit you coming in i
know i'd been bad and then she'd wait
there by the porch and as soon as i
tried to sneak the house wow yeah she
would hit me and i was like oh my god i
knew this was going to happen and she
gets me everywhere accountability my mom
who cooks a lot she'd have a wooden
spoon like an old school wooden spoon
and we'd do something insane and she
would hit us and if and it broke which
took her to a whole nother level because
it was my she stabbed you that bro yeah
but i think like especially with the
latino community and this i don't think
it's it's a minority thing but middle
easterns and the disciplining of your
kids and we were scared the fat like six
words that if your mother said put you
in your place six words wait until your
father gets home that i'm like no i'm
like i'll clean i'll kiss your feet
because if he knew it was over i think
that that's gone away in this in the in
this culture now is you can't even you
can't even tell them anything because
they'll get snitched like you can't told
me this you tell me that touch me how
much of this has to do with technology
and the fact that we don't spend enough
time it's big talking and and sharing
these ideas just throw an ipad at them
take this
people uh you know millions of people
are probably going to be listening to
this conversation because they don't
have somebody to have a conversation
with so they have to rely on patrick and
his friends to have a conversation and
to a certain extent that's great because
at least we're having a cogent decent
conversation
but i would almost encourage those
people once in a while to go have a
conversation with your son or your uncle
or your daughter or whoever because i
don't think that's happening and that's
what i see out of that story out of
highland park illinois that that's not
happening when you live with a boy
because this kid was a boy
and he lives in your house and you've
been there 10 years living in that house
with him and a reporter comes and asks
him tell me about him and you say i
don't know anything about him all right
you got a problem yeah and if that's
indicative of america we got a problem
yep i totally agree
you know uh final thoughts here how much
of a role does the president play
on how fathers lead their kids how much
credence you put on that or is it more
tv dads like you know how there was a tv
that will smith's dad whatever his name
was you know
uncle fell
and bill cosby was a you know he was a
tv dad a lot of guys that played the tv
that how much of a role you think the
president the leader of a nation plays
on how to help raise your kids quite a
little quite a lot what do you think
what do you think i'm actually curious i
don't i don't know the survey but what
do you think
you're saying quite a lot what do you
think i mean if he accepts it what's
gravit what i'm gravitating to is when
uh on the debate stage when they asked
hillary and trump to say one nice thing
about the opponent and hillary said yes
yeah you know one thing else good nice
thing i'll say about donald trump is at
least you've raised some good kids
that's great i mean that was great so so
if what you guys are saying is true
which a tough father produces great kids
then how would you rate biden's style of
raising kids because so i don't know not
gold because the product on how the
product is doing whether it's hunter or
all that other stuff and then you look
at a trump or you look at obama's kids
or you look at like i don't see michelle
being a passive passive uh me neither
yeah i see michelle being tough i don't
see obama being tough but i see michelle
being tough i see trump having an
expectation
oh i agree i think no i i agree so to me
i don't know and by the way let me tell
you i don't think this is an 18-month
thing since biden's taking house
i think this has been a conversation
we've gotten away from for a couple
decades you don't get to a point like
this overnight you get to a point like
this it's a gradual process of getting
there but to work it out of this place
it's not going to be a two-year deal a
four-year deal i think you use your
great expression earlier today on
another matter this man is an accidental
president so to use him as an example of
what's happening from the president's
world but by the way not all
kids are critical for instance he did
lose his son beau biden who was a
full-on military hero purple heart
lost his life in battle correct and so
that's like someone like him and the
other one is a lot different from hunter
who's a drug who's a full-on crack head
yeah who's a lot different from ashley
biden who literally i partied with at
tulane like back in the late 90s that's
a fair point it was a party girl like
so not all kids are the same just like
you know you have your four kids they're
not all exactly the same so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]